من جهته اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل
احد مستشاريه العسكريين برتبه نقيب ويدعى
مقداد مهقاني بعد اصابته بجروح في غاره
اسرائيليه على ضواحل عاصمه السوريه دمشق
فجر الجمعه وشدد الحرس الثوري على ان ما
سماها جريمه الكيان الصهيوني المجرم لن
تمر دون رد يذكر ان مهقاني هو المستشار
العسكري الايراني الثاني الذي يقتل في
الغاره على ضواحي دمشق فجر الجمعه
اما المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني فقال ان دماء المستشارين العسكريين
الايرانيين في سوريا لن تضيع هدرا واضاف
ان بلاده تحتفظ بحقها في الرد على اسرائيل
في الزمان والمكان المناسبين ووصف كنعان
استمرار الغارات الاسرائيليه على سوريا
بانها انتهاك لسيادتها ووحده اراضيها
واستمرار لدعم الارهاب حسب تعبيره